all right welcome to the livestream
going to focus today really on two
things the hearing earlier today with a
bunch of people that I'll talk about in
a second and tell you who was at the
Senate Intel hearing today but most
importantly the released James Comey
opening testimony from tomorrow and
arguably the most anticipated testimony
of this kind in a really really long
time and the opening statement from
James Comey has been released so we know
what he's going to say and as someone
was saying in the chat before I started
it reads like a really great novel and
we're going to go through it so two
links in the video description today
okay first link is to a PDF this is
James commis testimony for tomorrow okay
check that out I'm going to be going
through pieces of it shortly second link
is to the lawfare blog and they are so
it's an initial commentary about what
James Comey will say tomorrow that's
really really good so feel free to open
up both of those links I'm going to be
going through them I will also be taking
questions via super chat and on that
note if this is your first livestream
with me welcome number one number two
we're really live I'm sitting here
talking to you right now assuming that
at 6:30 p.m. Eastern Time on June 7 2017
if it's any other time then you're
watching a replay number two super chat
is on the chat moves quickly sometimes
but if you want to get a question or
comment that I will read and respond to
if necessary you can use the super chat
that's the dollar sign at the bottom of
the chat number three if you sign up for
membership or become a patriot a patron
during the livestream I will sing your
praises and thank you and talk about how
great you are live on the stream those
two options are at david pakman.com
slash membership for the first and
patreon.com slash david pakman show for
the second number four
there are moderators moderating the chat
obvious trolling and hate will get you
banned blocked call it whatever you want
okay
subtle trolling will probably not get
you banned because we won't notice it
because by definition is subtle okay so
feel free to start using super chat sign
up for those memberships patreon
whatever so let's let's start going
through together james commis testimony
so I am I have no easy way of showing
you the document as I scroll it so if
you want to use the PDF link in the
description and and page along with me
that might be the best way to do it okay
and I'll tell you what page I'm on the
link is in the description and we're
going to start looking at some of the
things here let's start at the bottom of
page two with the January 27th dinner
everything that leads up to that is is
more general about why James Comey
decided to start taking notes at his
meetings with Donald Trump and I want to
focus in because I'm not going to read
through every word here with you at the
bottom of page two the heading January
27 dinner which starts with James Comey
explaining the President and I had
dinner on Friday January 27 6:30 p.m. in
the green room at the White House he
called me invited me to dinner that
night said next time he'll invite my
home family turned out to be just the
two of them and then it starts to get
into the good stuff near the top of page
three the president started by asking me
whether I wanted to stay on his FBI
director with which I found strange
because he had earlier earlier told me
twice that he hoped I would stay I
assured him I intended to
he said lots of people wanted my job and
given the abuse I had taken during the
previous year he would understand if I
wanted to walk away and James Comey
immediately zeroes in in the testimony
on why Donald Trump would keep asking
about whether he wants the job saying my
instincts told me that the one on one
setting and the pretense that this was
our first discussion about my position
met the dinner was at least in part an
effort to have me asked for my job and
create some sort of patronage
relationship that concerned me greatly
given the FBI
traditionally independent status in the
executive branch skip ahead a paragraph
where james comey reports that the
president said I need loyalty I expect
loyalty and this next line near the
bottom of page 3 is just stunning it's
like out of a movie I didn't move speak
or change my facial expression in any
way during the awkward silence that
followed we simply looked at each other
in silence the conversation then moved
on but he returned to the subject near
the end of our dinner this is more
interesting than house of cards season 5
and I know people say once I get to
Episode six and seven of season five
it's going to get really good again but
through episode 5 of season 5 what James
Comey is describing here an effective
staring contest with the President of
the United States as the president of
the United States suggests to James
Comey that he needs loyalty and expects
loyalty there has not been a scene that
intense in season five of house of cards
through episode 5 which is as far as
I've gotten
ok so let's go let's start there
again this near the end of our dinner
now at the bottom of page 3 near the end
of our dinner the president returned to
the subject of my job saying he was very
glad I wanted to stay adding that he had
heard great things about me from Jim
mattis Jeff Sessions and others he then
said I need loyalty I replied you will
always get honesty from me he paused and
then said that's what I want honest
loyal T I paused and then said you will
get that from me as I wrote in the memo
I created immediately after the dinner
it is possible we understood the phrase
honest loyalty differently but I decided
it wouldn't be productive to push it
further last thing before we move on to
the February 14th minute meeting there's
this other paragraph at the top of page
4 during the dinner the president
returned to the salacious material I had
briefed him about On January 6th and as
he had done previously he expressed his
disgust for the allegations and strongly
denied them he said he was considering
ordering me to investigate the alleged
incident to prove it didn't happen this
suggests in
credible ignorance from Trump and James
Comey explains why here by saying I
reply that he should give that careful
thought because it might create a
narrative that we were investigating him
personally which we weren't and because
it was very difficult to prove a
negative he said he would think about it
and asked me to think about it
so what can we glean from this so far a
couple things number one James Comey was
clearly not comfortable with the types
of conversations types of conversations
and types of requests that were being
made by Donald Trump and that caused him
to approach the meetings with Trump
differently than meetings he had with
President Obama with President Obama he
did not take notes with the Trump
meetings he describes in the in the PDF
which by the way if you don't know where
I'm reading from and that the first link
in the video description is the PDF of
James commis testimony tomorrow which
has been released his opening testimony
he describes that he as soon as he went
out to the FBI vehicle after one of
these meetings immediately started
taking notes so there were red flags
here for James Comey early and number
two um it also points to Donald Trump's
sort of lack of filter in terms of what
he says to James Comey having either no
sense or total disregard for what isn't
isn't appropriate of a supposedly in
defend independent law of law
enforcement agency intelligence agency
like the FBI so this is already
fascinating now what we've learned and
I'm I'm you know I have no interest in
distorting or hiding what's here Donald
Trump said that three times James Comey
told him he's not under investigation
this document does not confirm that
three times Comey told Trump he's not
invested under investigation but there's
no doubt that by telling Donald Trump
you should think about that because it
might create a narrative that we were
investigating you personally which we
are not that certainly is Trump said
Comey said I'm not under investigation
that is not literally saying that but it
is effectively saying that if you do X
it will create the narrative that you're
under personal investigation directly
implying that you are not under person
investigation let's go to the February
14th oval office meeting ok this starts
in the second half of page four and he
describes in the first couple of
paragraphs to sum it up quickly because
it's we don't have to go into the
details of that that it was a meeting
with a number of people Kushner sessions
and that Donald Trump insisted that he
wanted to speak only to Mike Flynn I'm
sorry
only to James Comey about Mike Flynn
starting with the president began by
saying I want to talk about Mike Flynn
this was the day after Michael Flynn had
resigned in shame after lying about his
contacts with with Russian officials so
at the top of page five now of the PDF
that is the first link in the video
description if you're just joining us
the president began by saying Flynn
hadn't done anything wrong and speaking
with the Russians but he had to let him
go
because he had misled the vice president
he added that he had other concerns
about Flynn which he did not then
specify the president then made a long
series of comments about the problem
with leaks of classified information a
concern I shared and still share after
he had spoken for a few minutes about
leaks
Reince Priebus leans in through the door
by the grandfather clock and I could see
a couple people waiting behind Priebus
the president waved at him to close the
door saying he'd be done shortly the
door was closed here is one of the
arguably the key paragraph of this
entire PDF which is on page four second
full paragraph of the page the president
then returned to the topic of mike flood
saying he's a good guy and has been
through a lot he repeated that Flynn
hadn't done anything wrong on his calls
with the Russians but had middle misled
the vice president but without even
going further this is already
inappropriate okay and the Benjamin
whit's commentary on this on the lawfare
blog talks about this this is already
inappropriate in that you were supposed
to have independence here this is not a
situation where Donald Trump is
testifying or being questioned by the
FBI about what we now know to be an
ongoing investigation this is already
inappropriate it's not illegal but it's
already inappropriate Trump goes on he
then said
I hope you can see your way clear to
letting this go to letting Flynn go he
is a good guy I hope you can let this go
I replied only I being James commis
narrative he is a good guy I did not say
I would let this go the problem of the
president brief returned briefly to the
problem of leaks I then got up and left
out of the door
by the grandfather clock making my way
through the large group of people
waiting there including mr. Priebus and
the vice-president in the second to last
paragraph of page 5 James Comey
describes that he immediately prepared a
memo about this and discussed it with
FBI senior leadership let's now go okay
so what we've seen assess what we've
seen so far here Donald Trump claimed
Comey told me three times I wasn't under
investigation it does appear that Comey
intimated that at that moment Donald
Trump was not individually under
investigation so Trump at least telling
a partial truth there justice had been
reported by numerous media outlets
Donald Trump did ask Michael Flynn I'm
sorry
ask James Comey to lay off of the
Michael Flynn investigation under the
pretense that according to Trump Flynn
had done nothing wrong as reported that
is exactly the way James Comey will
describe it during testimony tomorrow ok
immediately that has been confirmed
according to James commis narrative now
is where we start getting into the new
stuff that I I was not necessarily
expecting from the March 30th phone call
so if you're just joining us and there's
over 2000 of you watching with me here
if you're just joining us we're
discussing the released Michael a James
Comey testimony that he will be giving
us his opening statement tomorrow before
the Senate intelligence panel the link
to the PDF is the first link in the
video description down below we are on
page 6 at the sort of near the middle of
page 6 starting with the March 30th
phone call and this to me is a whole
nother level
ok on the morning of March 30th the
president called me at the FBI
he described the Russia investigation as
a cloud that was impairing his ability
to act on behalf of the country he said
he had nothing to do with Russia had not
been involved with hookers in Russia
referencing of course that blackmail
file and had always assumed he was being
recorded when in Russia stop right there
if Donald Trump maintains never had
anything to do with Russia has not
really done business with Russia
other than that miss whatever pageant it
was just has nothing to do with Russia
why would he necessarily assume that
everything he's doing in Russia is being
recorded in other words would a average
person assume that when they're in
Russia they're being recorded maybe now
you would but that is a sort of bizarre
comment right I've never had been
involved with Russia nothing to do with
Russia and I've always assumed I was
being recorded when in Russia not
exactly the type of thing someone thinks
about who has quote nothing to do with
Russia ever sort of odd okay
back to James commies testimony page six
of the PDF he asked what we could do to
lift the cloud I responded that we were
investigating the matter as quickly as
we could and that there would be great
benefit if we didn't find anything to
our having done the work well he agreed
but then re-emphasize the problems that
this was causing him then the president
asked why there had been a congressional
hearing about Russia the previous week
at which I had as the Department of
Justice directed confirmed the
investigation into possible coordination
between Russia and the Trump campaign I
explained the demands from the
leadership of both parties in Congress
for more information that Senator
Grassley had even held up the
confirmation of the deputy AG until we
briefed him in detail on the
investigation I explained that we had
briefed the leadership of Congress blah
blah blah blah blah he repeatedly told
me we need to get that fact out what
fact is that the fact that Trump is not
being personally investigated at the
time okay second time that James Comey
confirms that assertion from Donald
Trump again I'm just interested in the
facts I have no interest in
hiding the fact that James commies
testimony tomorrow will corroborate
Donald Trump's assertion that Comey told
him that he was not under personal
investigation at the time no problem the
president went on to say that if there
were some satellite Associates of his we
did something wrong it would be good to
find that out but that he hadn't done
anything wrong and hoped I would find a
way to get it out that we weren't
investigating him skip the next
paragraph go to the second to last one
of this call he finished by stressing
the cloud that was interfering with his
ability to make deals for the country
doesn't sound like Trump right and said
he hoped I could find a way to get out
that he wasn't being investigated I told
him I would see what we could do and
that we would do our work as well and as
quickly as we could what's relevant
about this what's relevant about this is
that we did not previously know that
there had been discussion specifically
about the cloud that the Russia
investigation was putting over Trump
remember after the firing of James Comey
during the Lester Holt interview Donald
Trump said hey you know what the entire
Russia thing was a cloud over my head
and it was on my mind when I fired James
Comey what James Comey will testify to
tomorrow is that they had discussed the
cloud that Donald Trump felt was over
his head because of this Russia
investigation and I think given the
context and the comment earlier during
the Oval Office meeting that I related
to you earlier 15 10 minutes ago that
this is actually a persistent trend by
Donald Trump if not always directly like
with the Michael Flynn instance to
indirectly say Jimmy it'd be really
great if you could lay off the Russia
stuff right that is effectively what
Donald Trump is saying here and this is
why James Comey was right to be saying
hey you know what I started taking notes
after every meeting because I was
finding it incredibly disturbing what
was going on the other aspect of this
that I want to point to is this
half of page seven if you're just
joining us nearly 3,500 of you now are
we are looking at the PDF that is the
first link first link in the video
description here which is James commis
planned testimony for tomorrow about
Donald Trump the April 11th phone call
at the end of page seven this is the
very end of the document
on the morning of April 11th the
president called me and asked what I had
done about his request that I get out
that he is not personally under
investigation I think at this point this
is what we would call bullying by the
executive branch of the supposedly
independent FBI I replied that I had
passed his request to the Acting Deputy
Attorney General but I had not heard
back he replied that the cloud was
getting in the way of his ability to do
his job he said that perhaps he would
have his people reach out to the Acting
Deputy Attorney General I said that was
the way his request should be handled I
said the White House Counsel should
contact the leadership of the Department
of Justice to make the request he said
listen to this he would do that and
added because I have been very loyal to
you very loyal we had that thing you
know I did not reply or ask him what he
meant by that thing I said only that the
way to handle it that the way to handle
it was to have the White House Counsel
call the acting deputy AG he said that's
what he would do and the call ended
that's the last time I spoke with
President Trump this dialogue is
reminiscent of The Sopranos Jimmy I've
been very loyal to you you know we had
that thing together we had that thing
together what are you doing to get out
what I told you about what do you what
are you doing about that Jimmy this is
incredibly disturbing and I I now want
to actually let's pause there real quick
okay then I'm going to get into the
legal analysis and a couple of the
things real quick from from the super
chat Frank macwrite sent a $20 super
chat James Comey may have his recordings
memos isn't it just a case of his word
against Trump's Trump's Trump will deny
everything that's an easy for him who
would have the courage to call one or
the other a liar even so then what Frank
here's you're right this is basically
hearsay based on who
in the room at the time and it was Trump
and call me admittedly contemporaneous
notes by an FBI director meaning notes
taken immediately after such a meeting
are considered reliable testimony and
evidence they are generally considered
in proceedings like these reliable it is
not like you here generally hey
eyewitness testimony in criminal cases
is not generally reliable
contemporaneous notes from intelligence
professionals like James Comey are
generally considered reliable so James
you're thinking hey Comey says a trump
says be they deny what the other says
it's a NetZero
know these types of notes from an
intelligence official like Comey are
considered reliable Melissa Deline cent
to $5 super chat and saladin 67 cent the
twenty Canadian dollar super chat thanks
very much I do appreciate that
so the other thing I want to point to
we've been going through if you're just
joining me over 4,000 of you now thanks
to everybody who's watching we have been
talking about James commis upcoming
testimony tomorrow about his
conversations with Donald Trump is that
if this is your first livestream we are
live right now
super chat is on use the dollar sign at
the bottom of the chat for questions and
comments I will get to those number
three new members and patrons the number
two ways our program is funded are
through membership and patronage new
members and patrons will get live
thank-yous and shout outs during the
stream I will sing your praises but not
right now I have other other stuff to
get to as far as the Comey testimony you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership patreon at
patreon.com slash david package oh
please don't troll obvious trolling and
hate will get you banned I've been
seeing people getting banned here and
there as the chat goes by Daniel
Smeltzer one of our great moderators has
just blocked someone glooms skull one of
our other moderators who also moderate
our reddit discussion forum has just
blocked someone and by all means the
moderators have been deputized to keep
the riffraff down
and there's a particularly high amount
of riffraff today let's go now to the
second link that I've put for you in the
description to this YouTube video okay
it is a link to the lawfare blog
analysis by Benjamin wits about the
James Comey testimony okay
I'm not going to go through this entire
thing I encourage you to read this I've
bookmarked I'm going to be on a plane
tomorrow and I bookmark this entire
article to read in detail but I've
scanned over it already this is a really
really good quick reaction to James
commis anticipated commentary tomorrow
before the Senate intelligence panel
benjamin Wits explains the sort of
general demeanor of Comey and the
context in which he has prepared these
remarks as well as more specific
analyses about individual paragraphs and
assertions that James Comey makes I
encourage you to look at it one of the
one of the sort of general themes that
Benjamin with gleans from this is that
Comey is is talking about how
immediately he was a sort of alarmed and
distrustful of Trump based on his
behavior and how Trump's behavior caused
a change in how James Comey dealt with
the president that was not the same as
how he felt he had to deal with Pryor
with with Trump's predecessor Barack
Obama that's number one
the other thing that Benjamin whit's
points out and this is why anytime
there's testimony like this it's hard to
anticipate whether everybody will sort
of get it right and Benjamin wits
explains here and I'm quoting from about
halfway through the second link in the
video description it's hard to express
to people who are not steeped in federal
law enforcement just how inappropriate
these inquiries are okay this is
referring to the enquiries from Trump of
Comey particularly when they involve an
investigation in which the president has
such deep and multifaceted personal
stakes no they are not illegal
the president has constitutional
authority to ask for whatever
information he wants from his
subordinates in the exact
of branch but of course the president
also has the authority to give the State
of the Union address in Latin and have
it consists entirely of obscenities
directed at the Speaker of the House to
people who know the norms of federal law
enforcement the conduct described here
is closer to that end of the spectrum of
presidential behavior than it is to the
normal range whether ultimately a crime
was committed by the requests made of
James Comey by Donald Trump to stop the
investigation into Michael Flynn remains
to be seen it's in a sense a sort of
moot point because the president can be
civilly sued while President but it's
effectively impossible to charge the
president with crimes while they are
president of the United States and so
that's not if if Trump is ultimately
brought down by this it's not going to
be because of a charge of a crime more
than likely Jeffrey Toobin legal analyst
has written a few things about that
already and and and so I wouldn't put my
eggs in that basket but check out the
entire Benjamin wits commentary read if
you haven't the full seven pages I mean
it'll take you what seven minutes it's
about a minute a page to read James
commis testimony the question tomorrow
is going we know what the testimony is
right the question will be what else is
teased out of James Comey from the
Senators who will be on that panel and
my prediction is it's not going to be
that much although and what am I going
by I'm going by the appearance today
before the same panel by NSA director
Mike Admiral Mike Rogers assistant
attorney general Rosenstein Dan Coates
the Director of National Intelligence
and who was the fourth person on that
panel Oh Andrew McCabe acting FBI
director for the time being they
basically answered nothing and there was
a surreal moment I don't know if you
watch this if you didn't you can easily
find this there was a surreal moment
where Dan Coates was asked by Senator
angus King great line of questioning
what is the legal basis for your refusal
to answer these
and Dan coat said I don't know that I
have a legal basis I just don't think I
should answer and it is it was bogus I
think it was absolutely bogus if you're
not talking about classified information
if the White House had not invoked
executive privilege and if there's no
legal reason that you can come up with
not to answer it's basically just saying
I don't want to answer and all four of
the men who were on that panel today use
that answer I hope that James Comey
doesn't do that tomorrow we will see we
will see an able We Bought watching very
very closely let me do some thank yous
right now because there's a lot of these
that are accumulating we are suffering
greatly folks I wish it were different
but we are suffering greatly let me let
me actually show the articles first at
the hands of the YouTube advertiser
boycott the New York Times has taken an
interest in what is happening to and I
say happening to because we really are
sort of just victim observers in this
entire thing the YouTube advertiser
boycott which started as a result of a
Wall Street Journal article is crushing
the David Pakman show
we've lost two-thirds of our YouTube
revenue and that's money that we have to
make up because YouTube is a big part of
what we do it's a big part of funding
our staff salaries it's a big part of
paying for our studio and connectivity
and distribution of our show to 200
radio and TV stations it's so bad that
the New York Times wrote about the David
Pakman show YouTube channel problems and
you can read this article at david
pakman.com slash press additionaly wired
has also written an article about what's
going on with the david pakman show
YouTube channel called want a better web
here's an idea pay for it by davey alba
great article you can read that at david
pakman.com slash press as well so we
basically need to make up the money that
that's that's the bottom line here
there's a couple of ways that we're
trying to do that one is through patreon
patreon.com slash david pakman show this
could not possibly be easier you go to
patreon.com/scishow we have surpassed
1,500 patrons I love to get to 1750
before it's too late you can make a
contribution of as little as a dollar a
month every dollar basically replaces
the lost revenue
from three YouTube subscribers okay if
only 10% of our subscriber base pledges
$1 the problem is over and we can forget
about the entire YouTube ad boycott so
on that note thanks to Michael King who
just pledged $2 a month
thanks to Louise Tremblay who just
pledged $5 a month
and there's also a bunch of people who
pledged just before we started so I'm
not sure if they are actually on the
stream or not keep those pledges coming
don't think that because you can only do
$1 a month you might as well not do
anything if everybody did $1 a month who
could this problem disappears membership
you can go to david pakman.com slash
membership you can select either a
monthly or yearly membership you can
take that red dot and drag it as far to
the right as you want in terms of how
you want to support us and then after
clicking that red signup button on page
2 of the signup process there is a
coupon code field pointed out by this
red arrow if you want a 40% discount ok
if you want a 40% discount you don't
need to do it if it's not necessary
don't take the discount if you want the
discount take it you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 you'll save 40% okay some of
the great member benefits include that
every single day we do an extra show
called the bonus show just for our paid
subscribers that is one member benefit
another member benefit is that instead
of watching these three to five-minute
YouTube clips of our show by 4:00 4:30
p.m. Eastern Time members get a a
one-hour commercial free video the
entire show none of this waiting 90
minutes between 3 to 5 minute clips the
full show is available just for you
around 40 4:30 p.m. Eastern Time and on
that note big big thank you to Neil
Bolton who has just signed up using the
coupon code I voted 17 big thank you to
Jay David act Atkins Esquire who has
just signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the
one code thanks to Howard Buckley as
well as Jan grumble and Layla Alexander
all of whom thank you I mean it really
is flattering that that we are growing
our support base and listen if you've
been paying attention to how the Trump
administration is targeting not only
leakers and not only whistleblowers etc
etc but also targeting just media
outlets who are working with sources
this is a time when when you look at
that you look at what's going on with
net neutrality it's it's scary it's
scary and the YouTube ad boycott has
made it even worse for us and it's it's
really not a good situation so I
appreciate everybody support and I will
do another round of thank yous and
singing people's praises for doing a
great thing very very soon okay let's
jump back into the super chat and
questions okay clarf one two three four
if you're not familiar with Clarke one
two three four Clark one two three four
is known for sending spanish-language
super chats on the live streams to get
me to speak Spanish doing that today
with a five Australian dollar super chat
saying C la gente sigue por Shonda Trump
en este punto algo que alaikum Benza the
swing propene propria Dada para esto es
una falsa noticias so okay basically the
Translate here if the people keep if
people keep supporting Trump at this
point is there anything that would
convince them about Trump's impropriety
for them it is all fake news no I mean
the answer is no Trump has said before
he said many times I could shoot people
on Fifth Avenue and not
lose their support Trump has a core
group of supporters that either because
of ignorance or ideological commitment
or simply not wanting to be proven wrong
will never drop their support for Trump
that being said let's take a look at the
Gallup daily tracking poll to see where
Donald Trump is today in terms of
support I haven't looked according to
the Gallup daily tracking poll Trump at
38% of people and and that's more or
less where Trump has been roughly
between you know as low as 35 up to 42
or 43 38 s not good and that means that
there are some trumpets that are veiling
but there are some that never will $5
super chat from kitta tude s keep up the
great work thank you appreciate the
support
$10 super chat from DW Washburn hey
David do you think commis testimony will
nail Trump badly keep up the good work
well listen we already I mean what we've
been doing so far today in on the live
stream is going through the testimony
that has been released that James Comey
will be giving and we don't know what
questions there will be the the opening
statement from James Comey is not going
to be good for Trump I predict that the
Trump administration will focus only on
the fact that James Comey will confirm
that at two separate instances he did
intimate to Trump that Trump is not
personally under investigation or at
least was not at the time we don't know
if that has changed the Trump
administration will probably focus on
that of course we are going to get
confirmation of what's been reported in
the media that James Comey says he was
asked by Trump to drop the Michael Flynn
investigation which borders on
obstruction of justice and that Donald
Trump less directly was sort of saying
Jimmy drop it with the Russia stuff
talking about how the Russian
investigation is putting a cloud over
his head so there will be news tomorrow
but I think it will mostly come
particularly now that we've seen what
the opening statement will be the news
tomorrow will come from commis answers
borne on answers to questions posed by
senators Brian Hanlon has sent a $2
Super chat saying
thanks for sharing Phil iers has sent a
to British pound super chat good work
mate nice one all the best from the UK
Kendal Patel has sent a $2.00 super chat
no question or comment thanks very much
Kendall and Rosalyn Jones has sent a 15
British pound super chat keep up the
good work we'll set up regular payments
after payday next week regular listener
in the UK and Loera have yet has setup
has sent a $2.00 super chat no question
or comment so thanks to all of you very
very much appreciate it and while we are
added just a couple other quick these
are starting to come in Fast and Furious
so a couple other thank-yous new patrons
at patreon.com slash david pakman show I
said it if you can only pledge $1 pledge
the dollar and Lander Hierro Figueroa
has just pledged $1 per month and I've
said it and I'll say it again if you can
pledge more than a dollar by all means
do it and Thomas Robert has done that by
pledging $25 per month thank you so much
Thomas and by the way Casper Janssen has
edited their pledge from one to two
dollars per month so thank you to the
three of you and on that note real quick
and we will get back to the politics
more new members Christopher Murtagh
Murtagh not sure how to say that name
murder
maybe it's murder and it's an Irish
spelling that's interesting Christopher
murder and Manny Scott I guess that's
Amanda Scott short for Amanda Scott
thanks to both of you for signing up at
david pakman.com slash membership if the
normal membership rates strike you as
high for your budget you can use the
coupon code
I voted 17 on page 2 of the signup and
that will give you a 40% discount last
thing real real quick if and when we get
to 2,000 patrons at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I will do an entire
show in studio with my hair
as displayed here in this picture I
posted to Instagram about a month ago
this is what happens when I don't keep
my hair under control with the use of
various products and chemicals that I
can't really talk about on a pump in a
public setting but but maybe in private
session I'd be willing to talk about and
I've said that I am willing to do an
entire broadcast show to our 200 radio
and TV affiliates in studio with my hair
like that if and when if and when we get
to 2,000 patrons and we have recently
crested the 1,500 patron mark alright so
a lot going on there alright let's talk
about oh this is a good opportunity
actually let me real quick just cope
there's an interesting super chat I want
to deal with so Floyd the fuckbag
great name sent the $10.00 super Chat
cava our Bob our Bob sent a $2 super
chat saying
etherium is the future the new
cryptocurrency I believe Maria Romero
sent a $5 super chat and gr this gr
super chat this it relates to something
that I'm going to talk to you about
seriously here gr send a $10 super chat
saying sorry I'm late DZ was getting you
paid brother money in your the man
Kellyanne Conway back in pink baby I
hate her with so much love of my
distaste gr 2017 gr is referring to by
saying that the money is in gr is
donating six memberships to the david
pakman show for people who cannot afford
memberships okay and the way we're going
to do this is gr is known for these
incoherent rants via super chat that
you're seeing displayed here for example
and the way we in the past we've done
different ways of giving away
memberships that are donated by viewers
the way we're going to give away these
six memberships that have been donated
by gr is going to be that viewers are
going to be invited to send in their
version of G our type in code
rants and then Pat and I are going to
select the best ones and maybe there
will be an audience voting component
maybe not I'm not sure yet but that is
going to be the idea and as you can see
G are quite coherent via email
completely incoherent and known for it
in the super chat and very excited and
really really appreciate that
six memberships have been donated will
be available to people soon Courtney
Haynes has sent the $5 super chat proud
patron here keep up the good work David
Trump is furiously scribbling his own
contemporaneous notes on the back of a
napkin right now my thoughts exactly and
what you're getting at is that there is
going to be an attempt to discredit - to
discredit James Comey but the trick is
going to be James Comey did confirm that
Trump was not making it up when he said
Comey told me I'm not under
investigation personally or at least
wasn't at the time so Trump is going to
need to discredit everything James Comey
said except for that thing about I'm not
under investigation personally so that's
going to be enough to thread the needle
there Cherise Walker has sent a $5 super
chat just want to give a little give the
troll something to moan about and chat
yeah the trolls hate that the david
pakman show audience for the most part I
mean listen we've got a lot of trolls
when you're talking about politics
roughly half of the country is not going
to like what you're saying or at least
not agree with it we deal with a lot of
trolls I deal with anti-semitism on a
daily basis I'm called the cuck probably
a thousand times a week I would say we
get about 1,500 to seventeen hundred and
fifty comments a day on YouTube and a
thousand a week is too much but a
thousand a month there's probably a
thousand comments a month where I'm
called a cuck this is just sort of what
what it is and if it weren't for the
fact that to balance that out there are
supporters who understand the importance
of what we're doing and are contributing
and are here supporting that that's a
great thing and I appreciate that
Charisse Germain Zepeda $25 super chat
David don't stop
learning on trump's awful performance
you always hit the nail in the head when
you objectively report on this issue
Trump is a fake and a con artist and his
supporters can't see that great job
David
if supporters can't see that don't want
to see that or ideal ideologically
committed not to see that john paul hunt
has sent a five-dollar super chat
bitcoin versus u.s. dollar truth with
political correctness by the 2020s never
trust corporations as people post
citizens united i don't know if that was
translated by some kind of auto
translator but i don't know what that is
i don't know what the what you mean
there John Paul I apologize Shana Powell
$5 super chat
why do you feed into this Russian
narrative with zero evidence oh dear
listen I mean where do you even start I
don't even know if it's worth it Shana
because it sounds like you're committed
to never saying we should be looking
into Russia it's not normal Shana that
you have administration officials lying
about meetings with diplomats from other
countries and that the lies are only
about meetings with diplomats from one
particular country why are their line
why are they lying those lies are
concerning the lies have been included
on disclosure forms Jared Kushner
for example Michael Flynn etc if there
is nothing to see why are there lives we
could go on and on right and and you
know if all that will satisfy you is
video of Donald Trump and Vladimir Putin
meeting secretly on Trump's plane over
last summer you're probably never going
to be satisfied and this is when it it
makes sense to ask the Peter Bogosian to
feasibility question which is what would
it take to change your mind if the
answer is nothing you're not a serious
thinker right there needs to be
something that would change your mind I
don't believe
that Noah built a huge ark and put two
of each animal on it don't believe it
happened but my mind could be changed
and I could tell you what would change
my mind
reports of that Ark from outside of
so-called sacred texts scientific
reports that tell me it's even remotely
possible an explanation as to how you
separated animals that eat other animals
and when you had animals that ate other
other animals did you have to have extra
animals for them to eat during the time
that they were on the boat I mean I can
go on right but I have an answer for
what would change my mind about
believing in Noah's Ark if the answer is
nothing would change your mind about
Russia you're just not a serious person
if what would change your mind is
unreasonable and applies a standard that
you would not apply in other situations
then I think that that would be
something to be explored okay so anyway
Shona those are some of my thoughts
Chris rad sent a $2.00 super chat asking
whether I'm debating Kyle kolinsky on
Russia or not
nothing has been proposed I've said
before I don't know that there's really
anything to debate I mean the what we
know about lies that have been told
connections investigations those are
facts beyond that it's a question of how
important do you think that the Russia
situation is but that's not really a
debate but I've said I'll talk to Kyle
I'm heading out for a professional
development trip tomorrow so I don't
know when it would happen but I'm
conceivably I would gladly do that
always glad to talk to Kyle Paul
Thompson has sent a $5 super chat saying
learned that I get the New York Times
for free through my University took the
cash I saved and got a membership to
your show good job David
keep it up Wow well thank you Paul I
really really appreciate that
and a number of people continue to sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership
using the coupon code
I voted 17 I want to say thank you to
David Thomas who has just signed up at
David
mancom slash membership paying full
price I might add Melissa Wilson has
just signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership also choosing to pay full
price alex Charron has just signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership not
using the coupon code but don't worry if
you want to use the 40% discount coupon
code it's available on the second page
of the sign up and again this is our
primary source of funding and we do a
lot of really good stuff for our members
including a daily bonus show only for
our paid subscribers you can use the
coupon code
I voted 17 delineated by the red arrow
40% off you get a hundred percent of the
benefits for 40 percent off and on that
note thanks to a few other patrons who
have pledged at patreon.com slash david
pakman show as little as a dollar a
month means a lot see denoon has pledged
two dollars a month thank you
James McCullers jr. has pledged two
dollars a month thank you so much James
Marius Thomason has pledged $1 a month
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
thank you and Mary Ruffalo has pledged
five dollars at patreon.com slash David
Pakman show thank you so much we are
trying to get to initially 1,750 patrons
of and ultimately 2,000 patrons a lot
more questions here coming through the
super chat quirky box has sent a ten I
believe CHF is a Swiss francs ten Swiss
franc super chat hi David I recently saw
your picture on the website banner of
Ring of Fire do you work with them in
some way by the way our super chat
donation single payments or is the
credit card charge monthly no super chat
donations are individual nothing
automatic will be charged not only do I
well yes so if you go to TR o fire com
let me pull it up and see what picture
they're using now you will see that my
picture is oh nice placement on all the
way on the left
sort of first in some way yes I work
with them insofar as all of the hosts
pictured at the top of TR o fire comm
have their content distributed through
the Ring of Fire network at this website
but the professional development trip
that I will be taking starting tomorrow
is to none other than ring a fire
headquarters where I'm going to be
checking out their new studio and we're
looking at making some changes and
upgrades to our studio and I'm really
looking forward to it although I've been
warned they are in Pensacola Florida
I've been to Orlando I've been to Miami
Miami Beach is not the deep south I've
been warned that Pensacola is the deep
south and it's been a while since I've
really been to the Deep South because
I've been to Miami Beach I've been to
Austin Texas neither representative of
what it means to be in the deep south in
Pensacola with its closest city being
Mobile Alabama I've been warned not only
about the humidity but also about what I
should expect as far as the politics so
that's that okay gr has sent a ten
dollar super chat uh I mean this is this
is just wacky taro ex her amble Polly
fufu Chris rad God X of X path Clarke
one two three four DW Washburn and
anyone I missed it's absolutely my
pleasure to help to kind 2017 taro at
least someone knows they are Rimes thank
you okay
Clarke one two three four sent the two
Australian dollar super chat shout out
to Eli or Ellie of the discord he needs
our love yes there is a discord server
organized by some of our reddit forum
goers that is sort of taking on a life
of its own some of the David Pakman show
discord members had a debate with the
Kyle kolinsky secular talk discord
members
the viewers are generating all their own
content and it's just such a great
community so check that out info about
it at david pakman.com slash reddit
Kevin Carroll has sent a $5 super chat
late at night when I can't take it
anymore I scream
[ __ ] Trump into my pillow what do you
do to release your political stress or
outrage
I just take a break from it I mean I
really try to from Friday evening until
Sunday afternoon or evening which is
when I start preparing the Monday show I
really try to avoid paying attention to
politics this is why I'm not tweeting
that much on the weekends about politics
and I mean I feel completely like I've
missed you know 10 scandals by the time
I tune back in on Sunday afternoon but
that that's one way and working out I
recommend that that's a that's my advice
Getty Germany has sent a 5 euro super
chat if they can't afford membership
they might they might can't afford super
chat coffe Fe coffe Fe greetings from
Germany one o'clock in the night here by
the way someone tweeted me it's not
common that I get a tweet that actually
cracks me up and I laugh out loud
someone tweeted to me today David have
you tried making coffe Fe with David
Pakman show coffee beans which are
available at david pakman.com slash
membership at SlashGear rather i don't
know why it just cracked me up like how
would you try to make coffe Fe out of
coffee beans what would the first step
be I don't know a kind has sent a 20
Danish kroner super chat with no
question or comment thanks very much one
man one truck I recognise the handle has
sent a fifty dollar super chat
longtime listener of both you and
secular talk good luck with recouping
your lost revenue from YouTube ad cuts
keep up the good work thanks so much
really really appreciate that Steven
gray has sent a $5 super chat just
thought I would help out the failing
David Pakman show love the show well
listen with everybody support I'm hoping
that despite the horrifying reality of
the YouTube advertiser
boycott as outlined in a recent wired
article about our show about our YouTube
channel as outlined by a recent New York
Times article about our show I am
hopeful that we will be able to recoup
all the lost revenue and move on to
bigger and better things
Yoop at 65 has sent a $5 Super chat
celebrating the my first live stream the
my first live live stream and my very
first super chat yeah keep up the good
work David well thanks you Pat
appreciate that
- very 780 has sent a 3 euro super chat
maybe the most difficult to answer
question what do you think of James
Comey David I mean I that James Comey
made a mistake by not publicly handling
the Hillary Clinton email investigation
in the Trump Russia investigation in the
same way right both investigations were
going on before the election on November
8th but James Comey opted to only go
public about the Hillary Clinton
investigation I think that that was a
mistake I have not actually seen real
evidence that tells me James Comey was
trying to impact the election result I
could be proven wrong and I'm open to
changing my mind about that I think
Comey made a mistake and it set off a
shitstorm and by and large I have found
Comey to be a morally upstanding guy
check out the drama back in 2007 based
on what happened in 2004 involving John
Ashcroft and Alberto Gonzales check
Google it there's there or YouTube it do
a youtube search for a lot of testimony
about that so I generally think that
he's an upstanding guy I think he got
wrapped up in some mistakes and a lot of
nonsense and I'm looking forward to to
the testimony tomorrow frackle has sent
a $25 super chat saying simply hashtag
lock him up 21st century Mouse has sent
the five Canadian dollar super Chad
crisis and Bulevar en Venezuela if
government falls
do you think they will take Bolivarian
out of their name and is this
disrespectful to believe odd um I don't
know I mean listen I'm following what's
going on in Venezuela pretty closely and
I have been for years actually and I
don't know about the optics of you know
the whole Bulevar en Venezuela thing I
think that the people of Venezuela have
a real uphill battle and it's not a good
situation and I really feel Terrell who
moved back to Venezuela I guess it was
about seven years ago from the US and
I'm worried about them and everybody
that no doubt about it
Fryman sent the five euro super Chad
don't have much to say but here's some
money keep up the good work thank you
Janet Savoy has sent a ten dollar super
chat Leo it up
I need this show for my intellectual
intellectual health maybe keep it up
could keep be autocorrected to Leo I
think that's possible
says he canal is has sent the $20 super
chat thank you very much
tinfoil hat has sent the 20 Australian
dollar super chat appreciate that and
Zoey Kneebone has sent a $5 super chat
with no question or comment I really
really do appreciate that okay let me do
a couple other membership thank-yous
just because they're continuing to roll
in and I don't want to fall too far
behind Spencer Beale has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership using
the 40% discount code I voted 17 also
new signups from Barbara Moore thanks so
much Barbara really really appreciated
Jeff Phillips has signed up Jeff you're
the best Sam Carson has signed up and
Jessica Smith has signed up sometimes I
can't see the full name unless I
actually open up the email thanks to all
of you really really appreciate that and
also just incredibly briefly one new
patron as well Christina Parker
who has just pledged $12 a month very
very much appreciate that and and
everybody who's been contributing we
have some really really good stuff
planned for the next couple of weeks on
the David Pakman show first of all if
you don't listen to the podcast or
listen to the radio show or watch the TV
show after years of people asking me to
interview Peter Joseph from the
zeitgeist movement and numerous attempts
to get Peter to agree to be on the show
we interviewed Peter Joseph earlier this
week from the zeitgeist movement about
his new book which I don't have here but
actually where is it
in any case that I'll deal with that
later don't worry about that did a close
to half-hour interview with Peter Joseph
which was split on Monday and Tuesday's
episodes that standalone video clip is
going to go live on YouTube over the
weekend really good interview I
encourage you to check it out next week
we've got interviews with Jeremy lent
James Underdown and Corey Stamper not to
be confused with Doug Stamper of house
of cards Fame and we're already booking
out beyond that we've got a really
really good political correctness
long-form piece and this is a piece
we've been working on for a couple of
weeks and I'm going to address both
those who believe that political
correctness is a hugely stifling burden
on speech and those who think that there
is no such thing as overbearing
political correctness I predict that
either you will find it nuanced and
worthwhile and end and well researched
or you will think that by not being on
one extreme or the other of the issue
that it's [ __ ] and I look forward to
those comments look forward to that $10
super chat from gr was naming people who
said some kind words to me DZ and I
can't be a man of indignity so I was
speaking thankfully PATRIOT me maybe not
but I be assuredly a PAC matriot and
thankful
thankful to the low I genuinely question
my ability to read English when we see
these rants from gr and if you missed it
gr is sponsoring six david pakman show
membership s-- which will be given away
to the people who can create the
funniest gr type incoherent rants more
about that next week on the program
on that note my hour is up I've got a
pack I've got to make dinner I will try
to live stream from Ring of Fire Studios
over the weekend and we'll be back
before you know it with more in studio
content